let's say that I'm able to go out and
survey every single member of a
population which we know is not normally
practical but I'm able to do it and I
ask each of them what do you think of
the president and I ask them and there's
only two options they can either have an
unfavorable rating unfavorable
unfavorable rating or they could have a
favorable rating or or they could have a
favorable rating and let's say after I
survey every single member of this
population 40% 40% have an unfavorable
rating and 60% have a favorable rating
so if I were to draw the probability
distribution the probability
distribution is going to be a discrete
one because there's only two values that
any person can take on they could either
be have an unfavorable view or they
could have a favorable view or they
could have a favorable view and 40% have
an unfavorable view 40% have an
unfavorable view and let me color code
this a little bit so this is the 40%
right over here so 0.4 maybe I'll just
write 40% right over there 40% right
over there and then 60% and then 60%
have a favorable view have a favorable
view 60% let me do color code this 60%
have a favorable view and notice these
two numbers add up to 100% because
everyone had to pick between these two
options now if I were to go and ask you
to pick a random member of that
population and say what is the expected
favorability rating of that member what
would it be
or another way to think about it is what
is the mean of this distribution and for
a discrete distribution like this your
mean or your expected value is just
going to be the probability weighted sum
of the different values that your
distribution can take on now the way
I've written it right here you can't
take a probability weighted sum of U and
F you can't say 40% times u plus 60%
times F you won't get any type of a
number so what we're going to do is
define U and F to be some type of values
so let's say that U is zero
you is zero and f is one and now the
notion of taking a probability weighted
sum makes some sense so the mean the
mean or you could even say the you could
say the mean well I'll just say the mean
of this distribution is going to be 0.4
it's going to be 0.4 that's this
probability right here times zero times
zero plus plus 0.6 plus 0.6 times 1 plus
0.6 times 1 which is going to be equal
to this is just going to be 0.6 times 1
is 0.6 0.6 so clearly no individual can
take on the value of 0.6 no one will no
one can tell you I 60% unfavorable and
40% M unfavorable everyone has to pick
either favorable or unfavorable so you
will never actually find someone who has
a 0.6 favorability value it'll either be
a 1 or a 0 so this is an interesting
case where the mean or the expected
value is not a value that the
distribution can actually take on and so
you know it's a value some place it's a
some place it's a value some place over
here that that obviously cannot happen
but this is the mean this is the
expected value and the reason why that
makes sense is if you had if you
surveyed a hundred people you'd multiply
100 times this number you would expect
60 people to say yes or if you sum them
all up 60 would say yes and then 40
would say 0 you sum them all up you
would get 60% saying yes and that's
exactly what our population distribution
told us now what is the variance what is
the variance of this population right
over here so the variance let me write
it over here let me pick a new color the
variance the variance is just you could
view it as the probability weighted sum
of the squared distances from the mean
or the expected value of the squared
distances from the mean so what's that
going to be well there's two different
values that anything can take on you can
either have a 0 or you could either have
a 1 the probability that you get a 0 is
0.4 so there's a point for probability
that you get a 0
and if you get a zero what's the
difference what's the distance from zero
to the mean the distance from zero to
the mean is zero minus 0.6 or I can even
say 0.6 minus zero same thing because
we're going to square it zero minus 0.6
squared remember the variance is the
probability or the the weighted sum of
the of the squared distances so this is
the difference between 0 and the mean
and then plus there's a point 6 chance
there's a point 6 chance 0.6 chance that
you get a 1 and the difference between 1
and point 6 1 and our mean point 6 is
that and then we are also going to we
are also going to we are also going to
square this over here now what is this
value going to be this is going to be
0.4 times 0.6 squared this is 0.4 times
point because 0 minus 0.6 is negative
point 6 if you square it if you square
it you get positive 0.36 so this value
right here I'm going to color code it
this value right here is times 0.36 and
then this value right here let me do
this in another so then we're going to
have 2 plus 0.6 Plus this point 6 times
1 minus 0.6 squared now 1 minus 0.6 is
0.4 0.4 squared or 0.4 squared is 0.16
so let me do this so this value right
here it's going to be 0.16 so let me get
my calculator out to actually calculate
these values let me get my calculator
out so this is going to be 0.4 times
0.36 plus 0.6 times times point one six
which is equal to 0.2 four point two
four so our standard deviation of this
distribution our standard deviation of
this distribution is zero point 2 4 or
if you want to think about the
if you want to think about the weather
the variance of this distribution is
0.24 and the standard deviation of this
distribution which is just the square
root of this the standard deviation of
this distribution is going to be the
square root of zero point two four and
let's calculate what that is that is
going to be let's take the square root
of 0.2 four which is equal to 0.4 eight
well I'll just round it up point four
nine so this is equal to 0.49 so if you
were to look at this distribution the
mean the mean of this distribution is
0.6 so 0.6 is the mean and the standard
deviation is 0.5 so the standard
deviation is so it's actually out here
is because if you go add one standard
deviations you're almost getting to one
point one so this is one standard
deviation above and then one standard
deviation below get to right about here
and that kind of makes sense it's hard
to really rational to to kind of have a
good intuition for a discrete
distribution because you really can't
take on those values but it makes sense
that the distribution is skewed to the
right over here anyway I did this I did
this example with particulars because I
wanted to I want to show you why this
distribution is useful in the next video
I'll do these with just general numbers
where this is going to be P where this
is the probability of success and this
is the 1 minus P which is the
probability of failure and then we'll
come up with general formulas for the
mean and variance and standard deviation
of this distribution which is actually
called the Bernoulli distribution is the
simplest case of the binomial
distribution